[Music]
so much to talk about there is so much
of you guys yeah this movie very funny
movie but you're really showing a lot of
yourselves you both look fantastic thank
you yeah yeah Jason really worked hard
he did a great job she was I mean she
already looks good he said he really
worked hard the miracle of looking good
you asked wait you look well sighs you
did a lot of water ballet it's making
stuff up now ran over there all right
you parachuted for a while which doesn't
you don't lose weight at all in our
shooting saliva yeah exactly now you
know what in the in the movie I was in
treatment some of the movie because it
brought back something to my attention
in the movie your characters you want to
make a sex tape and you want it to have
a lot of exciting positions and you use
the joy of sex book yeah and that's a
book that I don't know if people still
know about that book but it was a book
that was around and it's still around
but it was like a book that sort of came
out and like what late 60s 70s something
like that yeah it's from like a
different more like felt pure there's
nothing sleazy about it
and they're like they incorporate food
they give you some what to eat before I
start digesting beautiful like like like
lamb tagine because of the the spices
and how it'll arouse you yeah this
doesn't sound that doesn't sound too
erotic at all to me it was pretty erotic
and then I remember I remembered from
the the joy of sex book I remembered
flipping through it and
long time ago and then again recently in
my garage but I was but remember
everybody was like the guy has a big
beard it's very early 70s you ever check
out it was a hairier time yeah yes all
over yeah he has a beard everywhere yeah
it shows the true evolution of man up
until now we can rivet so it's almost
like an archaeological reference yes to
a time when man used to grow hair yeah I
[Laughter]
don't want to get too personal you look
again absolutely stunning in this movie
you sir did you manscape it all for this
movie no I know I didn't know he did not
yeah with my body as is I like to feel
like the everyman however there is a
scene where I do a handstand naked into
the splits and I've never seen I've
never seen myself from that vantage
point it's pretty gross no one why would
anyone want to see that wants to see
that well that's the thing about what
our characters do for the video is you
know they're making the sex tape but a
lot of what they do is just sort of more
for themselves a commitment how to show
their commitment to one another that
they really love one another and the
things that they find frisky oh sorry
when the sex tape gets out what happens
is it gets uploaded to the cloud and
disseminated through their community to
their friends and family so when we shot
the sex tape scenes we needed it to be
as embarrassing as possible so they need
to rush to get it back and there's a lot
on there that uh it's pretty
embarrassing yes some of it
unintentional like I do they do
close-ups of our sex faces and I thought
I was doing a sexy face there's no way
as an actor when you're doing your sex
face you're probably channeling what
maybe you're really doing in real life
in that situation don't do that
[Applause]
right
I know it's like a lot of fans of Rain
Man yeah I know they look like Robert De
Niro it's food poisoning that's not so
natural to him that was horrific don't
ever do that again
you